the most obvious example of this of
course is the teachers unions so
teachers unions
are basically now saying they just don't
want to teach ever again now for my
money
i'm fine with that seriously i hope
everybody homeschools i hope everybody
pulls their kids out of schools puts
them in parochial schools puts them in
private schools
like take the money out of the out of
the public school system take these
teachers unions at their words
like they don't want to teach fine i
don't want you teaching my kids because
i think that you guys are basically
garbage added generally anyway
i think that the teachers unions protect
the worst teachers at the expense of the
best teachers
i think that you value seniority over
quality in your teachers
i think that you create ridiculous
educational missions that have very
little to do with the education of the
american public school child
so you guys don't want to come into
school good news millions and millions
of americans have realized over the past
year
they're not sure they want you teaching
their kids but if you are a member of
the democratic party
and your big push is that public
education done by teachers unions is one
of the jewels of the american system
then um wouldn't you stand up to the
teachers unions at this point and say
and say you know guys you really should
go back
to work there's a new study out that new
study suggests
that there really is no elevated risk
for teachers above the general
population that of course is not a shock
at all
we've known this for quite a while that
there really is no elevated public risk
in terms of the in terms of teachers
over the general population
in fact you would imagine they're
probably at less risk generally
especially if they are teaching young
kids
young kids are not transmitting this
disease in the same way that older
children are
it also happens to be the case that
younger teachers right if you're a 22
year old teacher
for second graders your level of risk is
really really minimal
it's much lower than you going to a bar
that same night but in a bunch of
different states we've got
bars that are open and schools that are
closed which is madness
according to the hill the chicago's
teachers union voted to defy chicago
public schools reopening plans for
teachers and staff due to coronavirus
concerns the union announced on sunday
the teachers union for the nation's
third largest school district decided to
allow all educators to conduct work
remotely
starting on monday the day kindergarten
through 8th grade staff were expected to
return in person so these are
specifically
teachers for young kids the ctu reported
86 percent
of its 25 000 members participated in
the electronic vote on thursday friday
saturday
71 of voting members decided to deny the
district's current plan to come back to
in-person learning
a ctu release said it means the
overwhelming majority of you have chosen
safety
cps did everything possible to divide us
by instilling fear through threats of
retaliation
he still chose unity solidarity and to
collectively act as one by the way this
just demonstrates
once again public sector unions are a
blight on the american political system
public sector unions would bargain
collectively against the taxpayer
and pay off the politicians to bargain
on their own behalf
it's one of the most corrupt deals in
all of american politics maybe the most
corrupt deal
essentially you now have unions that pay
to get politicians elected they then
negotiate with the politicians against
the taxpayer and the politicians
use the union money in order to get
re-elected it's truly impressive legal
grift
the chicago sometimes labeled the vote
unusually close for ctu labor actions
because 94
of voting members usually decide when to
strike
the chicago district official sent a
letter to families on sunday saying the
return date for teachers will be delayed
until wednesday
to allow for more time for negotiations
and to avoid risking disruption
to student learning now again there's no
science to back this
the science to suggest that these
teachers are at risk and that they can't
come back
until x y or z it's just nonsense it's
not true
in fact there are serious questions as
to whether this particular teacher's
strike is legal
under the regulations but it's not just
chicago's teachers unions it's in ohio
as well
according to wtol the largest teachers
unions in the state are responding after
governor mike dewine announced 96
percent
of public school districts in ohio have
signed a form committing to in-person
learning by march 1st
the unions including the toledo
federation of teachers say in a joint
statement
that governor dewine is using vaccines
as a bargaining ship to open schools by
march 1st
the statement says teachers students
families and cities will face dire
consequences if schools are pressured to
reopen before it is safe to do so
okay it's just a lie it's not true okay
so they're pushing that
new jersey teachers they say that they
don't want to come back
until every single student in these
schools is tested
again that is not first of all the false
positive rate on the test alone
would probably make it impossible to
open the schools but
beyond that are you insane okay the
children are not the chief vector of the
transmission
there's more danger of you hanging out
in the teachers union with the other
teachers than of you teaching the kids
okay perhaps the the greatest example of
this insanity is
members of the washington teachers union
claiming that reopening schools for
in-person learning
is an example of white supremacy and
saying that if we value the mental
health of students
that is a form of white privilege
according to the daily wire
echoing comments made by the chicago
teachers union months ago that reopening
schools for in-person instruction is
both racist and sexist
the president of the pasco association
of educators scott wilson made a series
of unhinged controversial remarks during
a pasco school board
meeting according to our friends at
jason rantz over at ktth
the comments were captured on video as
the board of education conducts its
meetings on zoom
amidst the coronavirus pandemic this
particular teacher's union head
compared the effort to reopen schools to
the riot at the u.s capitol
wilson said there are decisions to be
made you stand on the lawn of the us
capital as people break down barriers
and head to the doors do you follow
you stand at the governor's mansion the
crowd breaks down barriers to enter the
grounds
do you follow or do you choose a
different way we must not ignore the
culture of white supremacy
and white privilege he said we speak of
equity we speak
of the care of students yet we listen
and attend to voices saying reopen
everything i'm free to breathe
supporting
white privilege okay in reality the
people who are the most harmed
by all of these stay-at-home orders have
been children who are black and hispanic
because disproportionately kids who are
black and hispanic go to public schools
and particularly their parents need them
in the public school so they can go work
because in single-parent households
which are disproportionately in black
and hispanic families
if you can't drop your kid at school how
exactly gonna go to work that day
and this is madness so joe biden was
asked about all this right so joe biden
gets asked
about the teachers unions and whether
they should return to schools
and joe biden sidesteps the question
because again one of the it's amazing
you hear all the time about the
corruption of money in politics you
heard this from the bernie sanders crew
well there's so much money on politics
it's so terrible also i would love to
receive
a 100 million dollar investment from the
teachers unions
to go and do a knock for me i mean it's
just it's incredible
they're explicitly bargaining against
the interests of their own students
and then joe biden is out there
defending them
it is a high-level form of corruption
right in plain sight
the fact that labor unions have this
much power with our federal and state
governments is
nuts it's nuts and the fact that the
national labor relations act is so
biased in favor
of collective bargaining that would be
considered collusion if it were done
by employers but as soon as it is done
by employees it is now considered not
collusion but
something magical the nlra is a terrible
piece of legislation
okay but put that aside the very
existence of public sector unions
is in in most cases a blight on the
republic but here is joe biden
this is just an example refusing to
condemn teachers unions that are cutting
directly
here's captain science here as kids are
being put out of school
all across the nation again even though
we're reopening outdoor dining and we're
reaping indoor dining
here's joe biden do you believe
sir the teachers should return to
schools now
i believe we should make
school classrooms safe and secure
for the students for the teachers
and for the the help that's in those
schools
maintaining the facilities we need new
ventilation systems in those schools
we need testing for people coming in and
out of the classes
we need testing for teachers as well as
students
and we need the capacity the capacity to
know
that in fact the sa the sick of the
circumstance in the school
is safe and secure for everyone okay so
basically i'm just going to avoid all of
this by the way my kids have been in
school since the beginning of the year
no problem okay my kids are two of them
under the age of seven are in school
and um there's been no problem they've
taken precautions like masking they put
a little plexiglass on
on the tables the teachers are there the
teachers have not been infected but
apparently it's the end of the world
again the willingness of the media to
overlook the insane corruption
of keeping millions and millions tens of
millions of school kids at home
so teachers unions can sit at home
and get rich i mean really the unions
are getting rich not the people who are
members of the unions the unions
themselves
it's super corrupt how how tied in is
the biden administration to these unions
so tied in that randy weingarten was
originally considered a possibility for
secretary of education the head of the
american federation of teachers but here
she was this week
saying that she stands behind teachers
who are refusing to go back to school
of course we stand 100 behind the
chicago union but
you know the issue really is you know
just like we said last summer
when we said we would support these
safety
strikes the issue is we know that
in-school learning is really important
and vital for children
and so we are trying to take the steps
in different places
to make that happen okay so yeah those
teachers unions they're all for the
students though
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content